deep underwater four kilometers down
beyond the reach of our star is light
lie these dark potato-shaped nodules
they've been there for millions of years
slowly growing in size and these oddly
shaped bulbs May hold the key to an
electric future
we have known about these formations for
over 150 years in 1873 HMS Challenger
even managed to collect samples from the
mysterious abyss of the midnight zone
dropping kilometer long hemp ropes with
a collecting apparatus attached and by
chance pulling one of these nodules to
the surface
each of these lumps contain metals that
can help solve one of modern day's
greatest supply chain issues battery
production containing manganese Cobalt
nickel and copper and they are scattered
all over the vast sea floor it is
estimated that a patch of land just over
the size of Ireland can yield over 54
million tons of metals collectively
worth over 20 billion dollars
since their Discovery they've served as
no more than interesting seafloor
features given that the precious metal
they contain can be mined on land there
has been no incentive to profit off
mining the nodules but with growing
supply chain walls and growing
competition in the electric vehicle
Market dozens of companies now seek
innovative ways to surface these nodules
we know frightenly little about the deep
sea floor as you descend past 1000
meters all light disappears and thus so
does all photosynthesis the only light
that may be visible is the faint
twinkling of bioluminescence
without sunlight food becomes extremely
scarce and animals rely on what is
called Marine snow the falling debris of
organic material from shallower Waters
because of these extreme conditions the
creatures in deep water have evolved to
be some of the most unique in the Animal
Kingdom at 4 000 meters you may find a
semi-translucent Dumbo octopus scuttling
along or Culper eels with massive
expandable gullets or a Viperfish with
its terrifying dead eyes an unbelievably
sharp teeth deeper still scavengers and
detrivores scramble across the bottom
looking for any morsel of food they can
find animals like this have been found
as deep as eleven thousand meters at the
bottom of the deepest parts of ocean
rovs and some manned missions are
beginning to scratch the surface
exploring the depths of the sea but it
is no easy Feast only four crude
missions have ever been to the bottom of
the Marina Trench the deep sea being one
of the last ecosystems on this Earth
that has been largely Untouched by
humans
this raises major concerns for the
impact any mining operation will have on
the strange and wonderful life residing
among these metal-rich deposits early
investigations of the sea floor in the
1960s and 70s revealed that the nodules
are clustered in certain areas of the
sea floor
their locations depend highly on
environmental factors needing High
oxygenation levels and a source of metal
in the sea water or sea bed to grow
similar to how iron in steel reacts with
oxygen and water to create a layer of
rust nodules are formed in layers of
oxidized metal for a nodule to form a
piece of debris has to sink into the
oxygen-rich environment of the deep sea
floor
from above free-flowing iron and
manganese ions dissolved in water react
with the oxygen and form layers these
form nodules at the surface of the
seafloor
from below the metals get pushed up by
concentration gradients through the poor
sediment and once they reach the
oxygen-rich environment they react and
start forming nodules 10 to 15
centimeters below the surface depending
on their depth different percentages of
metal will be present
while the majority of the metals in the
nodules are manganese and iron surface
nodules are exposed to more Cobalt while
deeper nodules collect more lithium and
nickel
these layers form at astonishingly low
rates around 1 to 10 millimeters per
million years
in the time it took our ancestors to
spread out from Africa and dominate the
world these nodules only grew the width
of a human hair scientists can predict
where these nodules would appear based
on these environmental effects and we
have confirmed that they appear in
higher concentrations in the Pacific and
Indian oceans most of these zones fall
under international waters so the UN set
up the international seabed Authority in
1994 based in Kingston Jamaica to
organize and control all mineral related
activities related to the seabed
up to now they have not granted any
licenses for mining operations but they
have granted permission to a total of 19
exploratory missions of these poly
metallic nodules of which 16 are based
in the Clarion clipperton zone or CCC an
area just off the coast of Mexico each
of these missions cover an area of about
75 000 square kilometers approximately
0.16 percent of the area of the ccz
estimations for the potential yield of a
mine this large are expected to be about
1.5 million tons of wet nodules per year
a typical electric battery has 35
kilograms of nickel 20 kilograms of
Manganese and 14 kilograms of cobalt a
mine this large would provide enough
nickel for 400 000 car batteries enough
manganese for 18 million and enough
Cobalt for 100
000 carats per year
the value of these deposits is
undeniable but we've never extracted
solid minerals at scale from the sea
floor before this is going to require
new technologies and unsurprisingly many
borrow from the oil and gas industry who
are all too familiar with extracting
value from the deep sea
companies first have to locate a region
where the density of these nodules is
large enough to make extraction
worthwhile
autonomous submarines are first sent
down to assess the area using pulses of
sound to scan and map the sea floor
the resolution of these scanners is too
low to directly detect individual
nodules which are usually about 10
centimeters in size but they can
estimate the density of the nodules on
the sea floor before sending down
another expedition to collect physical
samples
now comes the difficult part extraction
many different solutions have been
proposed and there are several problems
to overcome
some trials were conducted in the 1970s
and 80s and the knowledge gained in
these trials all led to the same
proposals for a mining method
a self-propelled Rover would be lowered
to the sea floor attached to a surface
ship through a rigid Riser and a
flexible pipe these risers are
Technologies created by the oil and gas
industry and are well developed
once the collecting Rover touches down
on the sea floor it can move around
remotely operated from above the Rover
effectively acts like a potato Harvester
but instead of combing through the soil
most Rovers use a water jet to dislodge
the nodules and push them into the
collector now we need a way to transport
the material to the surface and this is
where most of the technological issues
are found
once the nodules are dislodged the
collectors carry the sludge and nodules
through a separator The Unwanted liquid
gets expelled Behind The Collector
causing a plume of dirt to trail behind
the Rover
the leftover slurry with debris and
nodules are now pumped up things get a
little difficult here raising material
over a distance this large requires a
great deal of energy
however attaching some kind of rope to
raise material isn't easily scaled
pumping liquid oil is vastly easier than
transporting solid materials currently
two main mechanisms have been proposed
to bring the nodules up to the surface
one way is to pump compressed air into
the pipe which creates the necessary
pressure underneath the raw material to
lift it to the surface however this
method has a very low Energy Efficiency
at about 15 percent the second option is
to space out submersible centrifugal
pumps along the rigid Riser this is
currently the preferred method once at
the surface the nodules are separated
from the leftover slurry they are then
dried out for transport to the mainland
however The Unwanted slurry that is left
over needs to be piped down and expelled
into the water column this slurry is one
of the primary environmental concerns of
deep sea mining operations
releasing at the top of the water column
where it can affect multiple levels of
the ocean ecosystem is not an option at
the very least we need to pump the
sediment down beyond the photic and
dysphotic zones these are the layers of
the ocean that sunlight can reach
pumping sunblocking sediment above these
layers would interfere with Plankton and
other photosynthetic organisms
an MIT study published last year
investigated the Dynamics of this
sedimentation for both mid-water
dispersal and for the sediment dispersed
by the Harvester Rovers they found their
models lined up closely with infield
experiments where they released sediment
in exactly the same way off the coast of
California they found thanks to the
rapid dilution in the sea currents that
the sedimentation race on the sea floor
was drastically lower than normal
background sedimentation and thus should
not interfere with Filter feeders in the
region
there was also no evidence of toxic
elements in this extracted sediment
while it's tempting to compare the
sediment to the toxic tailing pools we
see in traditional ore extraction these
toxic waters are a byproduct of the ore
processing this part of the process does
not happen at Sea this is simply surface
sediment being returned to the Sea
however even if the plumes of waste
product have minimal impact mining
operations have the potential to wipe
out species we haven't even begun to
study
sea sponges use the nodules as anchor
points deep sea octopus used them to lay
and protect their eggs and with these
nodules taking millions of years to form
any surviving members of the species
that depend on them would be left
without a home devastating an entire
ecosystem which we have very little
knowledge about or its impact on the
rest of the water column ecosystem
one of the few studies on the impact of
these operations was conducted in the
late 80s by a German government-funded
research Expedition off the coast of
Peru
to assess the effects of nodule
collection they carved out trenches and
removed nodules from an area two
nautical miles in diameter the first
seabed disturbances were created in 1989
and after 33 years the seabed floor has
not recovered the track can still be
seen to this day
filter feeders that depended on
suspended food had a significant
decrease in population and affected
areas showed lower biodiversity than
controlled areas
studies in other sites like the CCC have
also found a significant loss of life up
to 20 percent when compared to
controlled areas
however the sad truth is that the
alternative is to mine these materials
on land which itself comes with
environmental impacts the vast majority
of cobalt deposits lay under the Lush
forests of the Congo to collect these
Metals roads need to be built and
forests need to be cut down
another study compared the total
emissions of both land and sea-based
extraction methods and concluded the
deep sea mining of these nodules could
reduce emissions by 80 for nickel 76 for
copper 29 for Cobalt and 22 for
manganese these reductions are primarily
driven by how these nodules are
naturally occurring on the surface of
the seabed making extraction relatively
low energy and by the fact that ships
are incredibly efficient at transporting
loads
we also need to be incredibly conscious
of the impending climate crisis ocean
temperatures are rising and with more
and more carbon being absorbed into the
oceans they are slowly becoming acidic
killing off entire coral reefs we need
to transition to renewable energy as
soon as possible and these Metals would
accelerate this process
and there lies The Dilemma that we as
the human race have to ponder where do
we collect the materials necessary to
make a Greener future is potentially
destroying an unknown ecological System
worth it to save the ones we know for a
fact are in Decline is it easier to find
a new source of metals than to fix the
problems with land-based mining these
are the questions we need to answer
before exploiting this valuable resource
in the deep dark depths of our oceans
climate change is the greatest challenge
facing our planet and we need more
talented engineers and scientists
working to solve this problem that's why
I talk about it so much on this channel
and why partnering with brilliant to
help educate the engineers of the future
makes so much sense we created our own
real engineering themed chorus that you
can take for free by signing up for
their free trial and if you found value
in the math and science courses you took
for free and I'm sure you will you can
continue on with 20 off the annual
premium subscription our in-depth
interactive course teaches you about the
physics of orbit and traditional rocket
launches before teaching you the
fundamentals of kinetic launch systems a
course designed to help you understand
spin launch the subject of our recent
documentary you can get access to that
course right now and all of brilliant's
other curated interactive courses by
clicking the link in the description one
of my favorite courses on brilliant is
programming with python python is a
versatile coding language and a
fantastic first coding language to learn
it can be used for everything from video
games to data visualization to machine
learning I used it to code custom
scripts for engineering software for my
Master's thesis I wish I had brilliant
back then to teach me the basics and to
guide my learning instead of trawling
through textbooks brilliant teaches
python with interesting and fun
interactive courses that challenge you
along the way making the learning
process much easier and more rewarding
and they're adding content monthly so
there's always something new to learn
you can get started for free by clicking
the link on screen now and the first 500
people to do so will get 20 off
Brilliance annual premium subscription